Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Happy BAUWATIZE DAY!
Thank you so much for joining us today on Valentine's Day!
BAU BAU!
It's an extra special FUWAMOCO Morning today, ha?
Well, even though it's Valentine's Day and maybe it's a bit of a special day, there might be some Ruffians who decided to tune in for the first time!
So, let me explain.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Valentine's Day BAU BAU!
We have no jackets on because, you know,
It's a valentine's day.
It's a bit of a special day.
You want to give chocolate to Pero?
Why?
Well, first, Ruffian's Pero's not here.
So, you're gonna need to find him first.
But... One Ruffian!
Did.
Bought Pero.
Let's take a look.
Okay.
De-den.
You found Pero in your bed?
It looks like you even lit a fancy candle there.
That's nice.
On your bedside?
Just for you, maybe?
Yeah.
How did this happen?
Did you close all your windows?
You know, make sure the front door was locked.
Was it that
It was because you made your bed, huh?
Ruffians!
You might have not known, but Pero loves it when a bed is made nicely with fresh sheets.
You know, that's probably what attracted him to it.
Yeah.
Sorry, I don't think there's anything we can do to help you here.
You'll have to sleep on the floor while he gets to bed, okay?
That's the only solution.
Okay.
Don't ever make my bed, got it?
Unfortunately, that's one way to avoid situations like this, but... BAU BAU!
Complicated.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Ruffians!
As you might know, we had an amazing first collab with Chloe-senpai the other day!
And guess what!
Not only just that, but we also released a cover song with her!
BAU BAU!
Not here, but on her channel, we did BABYMETAL's "Gimme Chocolate!!"
Gimme Chocolate!!
Did you listen, Ruffians?
You did?!
Well, Ruffians, maybe you haven't listened to it.
Maybe you listened to Advent's cover of Megitsune earlier, you know?
When we had our New Year outfits come out and everything.
Well, if you like Megitsune, we really, really recommend that you go check out Gimme Choco, too!
We look so cool and cute!
Cool and cute too!
You know, maybe because FUWAMOCO...
Wow, we dressed up a little bit like Chloe-senpai.
We really, really love it.
You know, before the cover video premiered, we also used some special magic to do a karaoke stream to get a tune.
Did you like it, Ruffians?
We had so much fun!
You know, we sang a bunch of anime songs together like JoJo and Red Night Circulation.
And you know, it's archived on her channel too, so you get to go check it out now!
After FUWAMOCO Morning.
You have fun!
Well, you know, we are just so thrilled to be able to be invited to sing together with Kawaii-senpai.
And she was so sweet and nice to us too!
We feel really really lucky, so...
Thank you so much, Kure-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Genesis of a Queen was nostalgic, right?
Aishiteru!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It was a charity stream to raise money for cats protection in the UK.
Her goal is 50,000 pounds, but together with the deadbeats, she blew that out of the water and we raised a total of 80,000 pounds all together!
That's crazy!
BAU BAU BAU!
Congratulations to Calli-senpai and everyone who supported the cause!
And you know we had a bunch of fun together with Calli-senpai!
And looking at your cute pets, and Mario Party all together with Milky Queen!
But I think, you know, more than anything, we're just really amazed by everyone's warm support.
And Ruffians, we also want to say a big thank you to you for being there and for also donating too!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
It made us very, very happy puppies.
BAU BAU!
Wow, with today being Valentine's Day and everything, and you know recently there's been a lot of excitement about new hololive English words and events.
So, you know, we share an update about the brand new hololive English Valentine's Mix!
Because, well... We got some products for you!
Products for the Mococos!
Yeah, well... You know, Chishu, the Valentine's Mix includes a cute acrylic book charm.
You see right here?
Right here, you know.
Also the embroidered towel with the hololive English...
Also, it says MISS here, but if you get FUWAMOCO, it doesn't say MISS.
No, it doesn't say MISS.
It says ADVENT on it.
And you know, also the embroidery M1 badges too.
Yeah, just those ones.
They're pretty cute.
But if you purchase the set, you'll also get a handmade message card from us!
It's mine!
You know the embroidery M1 badges?
But, if you want a bit more valentine.
Oh!
Today is the day!
Hi!
You know it!
Definitely wanna have a listen to our Valentine's Day voice pack!
Okay!
You already listened!
Thank you!
If you haven't yet, today is the day, okay?
It's the day to do so!
It is!
Please get your paws on it if you haven't yet, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians.
Oh, you're gonna listen again?
BAU BAU, thank you!
Ruffians!
It finally happened!
Do you know?
Well, in about six months since we debuted, Moco-chan, you did it!
I did it!
I hit 200 sneezes together with you here!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
200, huh?
Moco-chan, actually, I searched it up, Ruffians, and this officially means that Moco-chan, you sneezed 200 times on stream within 197 days from debut.
Wow.
And that's on stream.
I sneezed the most.
That's something else.
Are you okay, Moco-chan?
Yes!
I think so!
Well, congratulations, Moco-chan!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Nothing to sneeze at, right?
What's a 500?
Oh, well, Moco-chan, since you know this is a very special moment, can you make a speech for us?
A speech?
A speech!
A sneeze.
Do you wanna hear a sneeze speech?
Yeah.
Ruffians.
To commemorate the 200 sneezes.
Why?
Well, I don't know, maybe it's a bit silly, but to me, I think that hitting 200 sneezes is, I don't know, it's a pretty big deal.
So, I'm happy.
200 sneezes is a lot of sneezes, okay?
It's silly, but it means something to me.
It means something.
Moco-chan, do you have any hopes and dreams for your sneezes in the future?
I think they're not gonna stop, so look forward to more, huh?
That's all I can say, okay?
You heard it, Mayans.
Look forward to more sneezes.
And in turn, more sneeches too.
BAU BAU!
The sneezes will just continue coming, huh?
Wow.
That's good.
Maybe for the Ruffians who are a bit scared of loud sudden sounds, sorry.
Ruffians!
I'm sorry to say, but there's been another misunderstanding.
And I'm pretty sure we did clear this one up already.
You feel that way too, Moco-chan, right?
It's chocolate.
Chocolate.
You know our newest song cover with Koe-senpai is Gimme Chocolate, right?
And you know we've seen a lot of comments from Ruffians saying, No!
Don't give FUWAMOCO chocolate!
They'll die!
Yeah.
Ruffians.
We talked about this, right?
When are we?
Ruffians.
We're demon dogs!
Demon dogs!
You know, we're tough.
We're rough.
Chocolate.
It won't hurt us.
No.
Dogs, however!
Regular dogs!
Yeah.
Not good.
So don't give dogs chocolate.
But you know, for us, FUWAMOCO,
We just don't really like it, you know?
It tastes bad to us, chocolate.
But, we're Ruffians.
You know, if it's made by someone we like...
We'll gladly accept it and we'll eat it and we'll like it.
You know, just like Biboo's brownies?
Yeah, yeah!
You know.
So don't worry.
FUWAMOCO!
We'll be okay even if we have some chocolate.
Yeah, okay.
But, to be honest,
We much prefer pon-de-rings.
But in case you couldn't tell, huh?
Thanks for reminding us.
You're welcome.
We're deeming dogs, okay?
Why did we say gimme chocolate?
Don't worry.
Don't have to worry.
Don't need to be scared.
What about pon-de-rings with chocolate toppings?
Is not the best.
Not preferred.
Regular pon-de-ring.
Thank you.
Mixed messages, huh?
No.
This is well explained, okay?
It just don't taste good.
Understood?
Understood!
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
No more misunderstandings.
Especially not on Valentine's Day.
Not on Valentine's Day.
Yeah.
And...
Well, Ruffians.
You haven't forgotten, right?
Forgotten what, Moco-chan?
Alice.
It's Valentine's Day today!
We said that like, not even 10 seconds ago, huh?
But!
You know it!
We have something else special for you!
Yeah!
You haven't forgotten, right?
Extra, extra special.
Right, right.
You didn't forget?
You didn't forget mine?
You forgot!
I don't see it yet.
I don't see it either.
Pup Talk!
Extra special!
Oh no, Moco-chan!
They forgot, so we just warned them.
I still don't see any Ruffians!
Ruffians!
There was many opportunities to look at our schedule this week, you know!
Many!
Unfortunately many!
Because we touched it up there many, many times!
Peter!
Thank you, Peter!
The cover!
A new cover song!
Yes!
Did you not want it that hot?
Ruffians, we prepared an extra special.
It's not ready yet!
It's for Valentine's Day.
You forgot it, just because it's not exactly on Valentine's Day.
Valentine's Day is already very busy, okay?
Yeah.
Well.
Cover it tomorrow.
If we did it today, Ruffians, it'd just be too busy for Valentine's Day.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm sorry you had a bajillion things for us.
Ruffians.
Hi.
It's okay.
Wow.
I thought, you know, I knew a cover song's coming out and Moco-chan sent the Ruffians, I forgot.
What is it coming out?
Well, I'll be kind.
And I'll remind you, but!
Yeah?
You have to promise that you'll be there, okay?
Because you forgot!
Especially.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's premiering tomorrow at 6pm PT, okay?
It's for Valentine's Day.
It's Valentine's Day.
Even though it's a little present.
Yeah.
But Ruffians, we did give you a hint, although I'm sure you've forgotten.
Do you have any idea what the song might be based on the hint that you forgot?
Huh?
It's called Valentine's Dream.
Now I'm starting to wonder, do we have it on our schedule?
Yes!
You wanna see?
Do you wanna see?
I will show the proof!
Okay!
There!
Right there!
I see it!
It says Thursday!
It has not moved once!
Thursday!
Special text.
Song cover release!
And look, the afterparty is there too!
White Love.
For some reason, I don't think we can release that.
Because it's already released!
FUWAMOCO-chan.
It's a present for the Ruffians.
It's a special font so you pay attention to it more.
It's nice and cute and shiny.
Cute and shiny is not what the Ruffians want, I guess.
But I'm sure you'd like to know what song it is, right?
Now that we teased you a lot.
And made you say sorry lots and lots.
Have you said it enough?
Well, you know, because it is Valentine's Day, it's probably a little bit of a cute song, right?
And, well, you know, FUWAMOCO, I kind of like anime.
Just kind of.
Right.
So I'd say, you know, Ruffians, if you're a big anime fan like us,
You'll definitely know this song.
But!
Maybe it's a bit older.
Ninja school!
It's not Valentine's Day!
Well, it's from an anime with...
I think it's time for a drumroll.
A drumroll?
I was gonna give another hint, but I don't think there's a hint.
I guess that's a lovely song, but a little bit of a different... A little bit of a different vibe.
Drumroll time!
Moco-chan, can you make it a special drumroll?
Okay, Ruffians!
All together!
We're gonna be releasing a cover of Let Me Be With You from the IMAX Holdings!
BAU BAU BAU!
We're so excited because this is a song that we've loved for many, many years!
We really love the feeling of the song and you know that we are excited.
We hope that you look forward to it!
I know, we think it turned out really nicely.
So we hope you'll be there for the premiere on Thursday tomorrow at 6pm PT, okay?
Don't forget again!
Yeah.
Okay, you forgot one.
You're forgiven.
Don't forget again.
BAU BAU!
Not today.
Tomorrow.
It's tomorrow.
But today we... There's other stuff here.
Well, Moco-chan.
It's okay, you know all the Ruffians were right.
We did make it a bit of a busy Valentine's Day.
Is that our fault?
Well, I guess it makes sense if they have Valentine's brains.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay, next.
Next Valentine's Day.
No, Moco-chan.
No, couldn't do that.
It'd be hard for FUWAMOCO.
But, huh, well, Ruffians.
I know Valentine's Day might be a little bit rough.
So, Moco-chan, maybe...
Do you have something you could say that would make us feel a little bit fluffier?
Maybe a little bit fuzzier?
Do you wanna hear?
Okay, maybe.
Ruffians!
It's that day of the week!
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
Well... Happy Valentine's Day!
Yeah, in case you forgot, it's Valentine's Day!
That means it's a day for happiness and love between all the important people in your life, okay?
So, you might think it's all about receiving gifts or warm messages, but it's actually the opposite, okay?
It's about sending those messages, Ruffians, okay?
So make sure today you let those that matter to you know that they matter.
You know, and if you don't get any chocolates, oh well, they don't taste good anyways.
So make sure you not only treasure those in your life that are close to you, but
Also make sure to treasure yourself and tell yourself.
You matter!
Got it?
Let's all keep doing our best.
Today too, okay?
Have a happy Valentine's Day!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Don't forget, okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Happy Valentine's Day.
Ruffians!
We looked at a bunch of cute pets yesterday, but today is special Valentine's FUWAMOCO Morning.
Who's our Doggie of the Day today?
Our Doggie of the Day is De-den!
Cute!
You see Kida!
Kida's all dressed up here!
Looking so cute!
Maybe she's going to revive us if we eat too many sweets today!
Apparently Kira's number one way of healing is through boobs.
That makes sense!
Boobs please!
Boobs!
BAU BAU!
Well, how does Kira BAU BAU?
Oh, like a... "I need a potion" kind of BAU BAU!
Aw, Ultraman... No, that's Kida!
That's how Kida BAU BAUs!
Not how Ultraman BAU BAUs!
No, it's not the same, okay?
Well, you know, Kida... Kida is super fluffy!
Just like me!
Or just like a cloud!
Yeah, which is good because, you know, I'm sure she'll pull you back down to Earth
If you're feeling like you had too much chocolate on Valentine's Day... I have something I wanted to say!
Huh?
Whatever, Mococo.
I think Kida is also like Mococo!
Fuzzy.
Thank you for always being there for your Ruffians, Hina!
BAU BAU!
And for the day I went on a walk, we have... De-den!
Fashionable!
It's a little scary.
Ima omoitsuita.
It's pretty cute.
I think it's cute.
Thank you for sharing this very cute, a little scary Valentine's Day sighting with us.
We're glad it brightened up your walk a bit.
It didn't scare you, okay?
Ruffians, it's kind of spooky.
Demonic.
Hey!
Be nice, okay?
It's Valentine's Day, okay?
BAU BAU!
I hope you have a very nice Valentine's Day walk today, Ruffians.
A nice day for a walk.
BAU BAU!
And next, for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Valentine's is all about love, right?
Lots of stuff, lots of stuff.
So, what are the qualities and traits that you want out of someone you love?
What are the things that you want to see in an ideal romantic partner?
Oh, uh...
Well, we haven't really thought seriously about something like this.
Ruffians, what are you making that face for?
Maybe, maybe not.
FUWAMOCO!
Kinda silly.
Kinda silly, huh?
Maybe not.
Someone that will appreciate our silliness because we're really silly!
Yeah, I guess.
Someone that's ready to be dragged on adventures even when they don't want to be.
Like, I'm on a pondering now!
We're gonna find a pon-de-ring!
Right.
Someone that enjoys the silly things that we like to.
Yeah, and I guess someone who will understand even if we're a little bit selfish at times too.
Right!
No!
I don't know.
I feel like some people may think it's a silly answer, but I don't know.
Personally, I think it's everything.
It's everything to us.
And Ruffians, you remember we can smell if you're a good or bad person, right?
Yeah.
Got it.
You know, I think that someone that respects you is very, very important.
And you know, and loves all the little quirks you have.
You know, someone that you can enjoy spending time with always.
You know, that's the type of person that I hope Raiden, and Rose, and Toei, and Yaily, they all find too hot.
Yeah, I don't know if they...
I don't think it's working, huh?
But I hope so too!
You know?
Yeah.
Yeah, huh.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your submissions and for Valentine's submissions!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Well, I'm sure we're gonna have an amazing start to our day today on Valentine's!
BAU BAU!
Well, but...
I hope you remember this next stuff, huh?
Ruffians remember this one.
Yeah, that's okay.
It's been busy.
I'm happy about that.
Because it's definitely on our mind!
Our next theme is... Our Valentine's Day theme.
It's tonight, Ruffians!
We're really nervous.
Yeah.
Our first Valentine's Day.
We've prepared a lot though, so we really hope you'll be there.
What if some Ruffians don't know what this is, huh?
Well, it's important you're there because you make the choices.
So if you're not there, well... We don't know how it might go.
No.
So, we hope you'll be there!
And afterwards...
We have a continuation together with the Doggy Pack!
Doggy Pack, we hope that you'll join us for the continuation afterwards after our Valentine's Day together with you!
BAU BAU!
And if we take another look at our schedule, Ruffians, you can see!
On Thursday the 15th, we have a song cover release!
Yes!
Let me be with you from 2 bits!
Please don't forget again!
Please don't forget!
We're really excited for it!
We put a lot of love into it!
Because, well, us, the Ruffians, you know how much music is really important to us, and how much we love singing, so we really hope that you'll be there for the premiere, that you'll listen to it lots, okay?
Yeah.
Which is a song that's important to us.
So maybe you might not know it, but you'll be happy if you listen to it.
I'm sorry, okay?
Okay.
As long as you're there.
Well, that's the end of our Valentine's Day plan.
It kind of goes on to two days, huh, Moco-chan?
Or three days?
It's Valentine's week?
It's Valentine's!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for a very special Valentine's Day FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Chichino Jack!
BAU BAU!
Pia.
Iho.
BAU BAU!
Zenon.
Mii.
BAU BAU!
More enjoyer.
Eldory.
BAU BAU!
Ponglin.
Hanpen.
BAU BAU!
Titanic G. BAU BAU!
Giant Rod.
BAU BAU!
SB129.
Donut-tan!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
And Happy Valentine's Day!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!